on January 23 2014 a mystery emerges
that will take investigators from the
deserts of Mars
to the birth of one of the greatest
civilizations on Earth
there's an obvious crater in the
landscape here in Mexico but it's not so
much the crater that catches my
attention it's what's inside this crater
this is intriguing because what we're
seeing is this white color and boy it
sure does look like ice
so unusual because we're talking about
Mexico and this white patch stays here
all year round
the mystery white crater is one of a
cluster known as the seven luminaries
which when viewed from above mirror the
Ursa Major constellation
[Music]
to NASA's Kasha Patel this
extraterrestrial connection may be more
than just coincidence
this crater reminds me of something but
it's not on Earth this crater looks
pretty similar to the Kora love crater
on Mars
[Music]
the core live crater in the northern
lowlands of Mars
contains enough water ice to fill almost
a billion Olympic swimming pools
most of the ice found Elsewhere on Mars
is mixed with frozen carbon dioxide but
it appears that the icy regions in the
core love crater are composed of more
pure water
the crater is named after Visionary
rocket scientist Sergey koralev
who during the Cold War helped the
Soviets to outsmart NASA by Landing the
first spacecraft on the moon
in a twist of fate the space agency
hopes his legacy will be key to the
Future human colonization of Mars
[Music]
ice is such a precious commodity for
humans it can also be used as Rocket
Fuel
if you can make hydrogen and oxygen on
Mars fill your rocket for a one-way trip
and then you gas up on the other end and
you fly back to the Earth
what stops the ice from melting during
Mars's 70 degree Fahrenheit daytime
temperatures is a process called cold
trapping
cold air goes into the crater
and it forms sort of an insulating layer
so any other water gets trapped there as
Water Ice
could we be seeing the same process in
action in this image
our planet's atmosphere is 100 times
thicker than on Mars
creating swirling winds which prevent
cold trapping from taking place here in
Mexico
it's a very Dynamic atmosphere
atmosphere that tends to even out the
environment
so this is something very different that
we're looking at
according to those who live nearby the
crater did once contain water but it was
bleach-like and killed everything it
touched
two geologists this suggests the mystery
white substance is the legacy of a
catastrophically powerful volcanic event
this means the water inside this crater
is extremely alkaline that tells me that
this is most likely sodium bicarbonate
very broad but it's very shallow this
crater has all the classic features of a
mar volcano
Mar volcanoes are formed by phreatic
eruptions which are known as the nuclear
bombs of the natural world
swim shallow magma intrudes into an area
that has a lot of groundwater
it creates an amazing amount of energy
vaporizes this water and it creates a
steam explosion
for the explosion water fills into the
bottom of the crater
sometimes you can get volcanic gases
still seeping in so you end up with this
highly alkaline volcanic soup
time the ground around the crater dries
out
concentrating the volcanic soup into a
chemical sludge
as that water evaporates it concentrates
further until we get these large fields
of crystals that form which is what we
see in the image
scientists have recently discovered the
crater's floor is covered with a
cyanobacteria called spirulina
spirulina itself is a very simple
organism but over history it's been
considered a superfood
what we found is the Aztecs used it as
one of their primary food sources
they'd Harvest large quantities of it
they considered it the food of the Gods
around 100
000 years after it devastated this part
of Mexico this strange white crater may
have helped give rise to one of the
greatest civilizations in history
this is almost like a museum of the
Earth's earliest prehistory it's a
fascinating place
July 18 2019.
high above Kansas eyes in the sky
capture something out of place in a
farming Community Far Below
first glance it looks normal
but if you look closer there's some
structures here that a farmer would not
have on their Homestead
a double security fence surrounds a 105
foot diameter flat concrete platform
and a close analysis of the approach
Road reveals this is no ordinary
structure
paying attention to the Shadows is
really important here where the road
comes into the compound the Shadows
really give the impression that the road
doesn't stay flat but actually dips down
is this compound hiding secrets that are
somehow related to a more Sinister
purpose
military analyst Carlo Munoz finds some
historic images that seem to confirm
that this rural landscape conceals a
terrifying Secret
the remote location the security
perimeter what looks like an underground
bunker is the launch site for a nuclear
missile
Declassified military records confirm
this location was one of a series of top
secret bunkers
armed with Atlas e nuclear missiles
the atlas missiles were the first
intercontinental ballistic missiles
armed with enough destructive power to
destroy a city the size of Moscow or St
Petersburg
what puzzles analysts is that the atlas
e was mothballed in 1964.
but the missile silo doesn't appear to
be abandoned
look at the satellite images you'll see
the road you see the cars you see a
digger so you know there's activity
happening at this site right now